right let's start so in the first talk
of the last session will tell us about
explaining some coding usually
all right this is today I'm going to
talk about our recent work in the past
year about explaining self-solving using
cultural reasoning this is a joint war
with Arijit Shah Theodore baluta Marisol
and kudib Samir I think uh RJ and gudiba
in audience
solving has been making significant
progress in the last few decades and
people are now using data server as a
powerful Black Box in meta systems and
every year in a sad competition new
solver come out and a new technique come
out and more and more Hardware Benchmark
can be solved however as Korean
indicated in his talk we don't really
understand how set a solver works we
don't know why the the Power Tour we
built or perform and reasonably well on
these hard MP problems and we don't know
why sometimes it gets dark on simple
benchmarks with even like hundreds of
variables and in this talk as the first
step towards this end we use a color
reason try to understand how sad Star
War works
you may argue that actually we learn we
have known that how the status all works
there are some use of some like uh we
know Clauses with low LPD have greater
utility here LBD is short for lateral
blocks distance it defines the number of
distinct decision
levels of literals in your class and we
use a utility as a measurement of how
useful the clouds will be in the future
solving
we will come back to its former
definition later in stock now right now
let's assume like the utility as a
measurement of the usefulness of the
clouds and the higher the value is the
more useful it will be
and yeah you may argue that we have no
Clause below LPD Cloud will load our
build value have greater utility Council
have used this heuristic in uh Cloud
deletion heuristics and we implement the
resulting solver and found that the
server performed pretty well right and
also you can argue that a small class
has greater utility and we have uh in
modern set solver we always prefer the
small class which contains like maybe
one liter or two literals but for the
large cloth it contains more than like
five or six collateral literals we will
remove it shortly
yeah you may argue that we have known we
run a lot of a lot of empirical on
experiment and we found this result but
does it mean we really understand how
SAS store works
here is an example so in my hometown uh
there is a strong correlation between
the cells of ice cream and cells of the
air condition
during summer people start to buy more
and more ice cream and also the sales of
the air condition increases and in the
winter people don't want to buy more ice
cream and also the sales of the air
conditioner jobs as well and apparently
we can find a strong positive
correlation between the cells of aspirin
and the cells of air conditioner if I
own a shop owner store like to sell the
air conditioner I can use the the sales
ad screen as a good predictor for the
cells of air conditioner right but
doesn't mean I really understand how how
that works
because in reality we know that the
cells of ice cream does not cause the
cells of air conditioner right and if we
look at this scenario for a little bit
well we realize that temperature is a
real reason because temperature causes
both the cells of ice cream and cells of
air conditioner
this may also happens in contact for
self-solving there may be some potential
factor which affects both outputent but
also tells that we don't know
let's come back to the stat solving
in order to understand how the sensor
works we collected a bunch of the
statistical data about the factors
inside the cell solving for example the
propagation it defines it represents the
number of propagations the solve the
Clause was involved and the user recent
it represents a number of conflicts
since the class was used in the previous
conflict conflict analysis it's very
variable a factor user recent
representation at this point we're
looking back what was the last time this
class was used in the conflict analysis
and then we calculate the difference
between the time step
and we found that there was a strong
strong correlation between them because
if the class was used more often in the
propagation we found that this Clause
would also use the more risk than the
config analysis
but does it mean that we uh understand
how why we have this kind of correlation
why this works why we can use the
population as a good predictor for the
user you use the recent
if we use color reading we can find that
actually there is a potential Factor LBD
which caused it both propagation and use
recent
which is a real explanation for this
correlation
and in order to identify this kind of
potential factor and also better
understand how the stats of server works
we propose uh our approach based on the
cultural reasoning
and here I showed overview of our
approach
and the first our approach starts with
the data generation because in order to
understand how how solver works the
first step is to shatter the data about
the factors we want to analyze
a bunch of benchmarks and we can we
collect the data during the solving like
uh what's the branching risk that you
are using and what's the size for the
class and what's our video of the cloud
and and the class will tell you
and after we collect the this statistic
data about the factors we can run some
standard structural learning algorithm
to uh to learn
causal relationship between these
variables then call the graph as room
here it represents that LBD called this
uh boss propagation as us recent and
propagation causes the user recent
and after that we can encode the
question of our of our interest into
account query and
for example if you are interested in the
question which clause with low or high
LBD has greater utility we can encode
this problem into a this question into a
cloud inquiry asking for the impact of
the LBD on cloud utility
after we get to Priority we can use
color reason to calculate the cloud
effect and use the result to answer the
original question
in a following slide I will look into
each component in detail
let's start with the data generation as
we if you want to understand how sets
all work how to generate the data about
the fact factors we want analyze we
collect them and we use and set formulas
later I'll explain why we need and set
formulas we collect these uncell
formulas from the site complication
benchmarks over the past few years
and we ran a status solver and collect a
bunch of data during the solving such as
a branching heuristic and Cloud size the
LBD of the cloth and also the time and
Main slider how long has this Clause
existed and also clouds utility
if you ever came from a definition for
the cloud security it represents the
number of attempts a clause has been
used in accept proof during the next 10
000 conflicts
uh maple
Maple is the characteristic used in the
maple sour the question is what it
doesn't make for me omega is a branch
Harris they used in medical server
what exactly does used in onset you'll
have to repeat what does use in answer
approved mean
so the use in the I said Pro yeah you
have to highlight that using assault is
different from the use in the concrete
analysis that's why we need a cell
formula we start from the final empty
clause and we run the device proof and
we found out how many times this Cloud
was actually used in the proof
sometimes your general sum Cloud we
should not use the you know final proof
but is this the actual set solver proof
or is it what you get from direct trip
this is a sensor proof
it's there a trip
okay which is okay which is very
different from what the SATs already did
but okay yes
and we uh yeah so that's why we have to
uh collect this data after solving is
finished starting from the conflict of
empty cross and use the red Pro to
figure out what's the value for the
class we're taking and we use this value
to indicate the usefulness of the clouds
and note that we generate the data using
the crystal ball framework which is
deleted by mate
yeah so after we get to the statistic
data about the factor we want to analyze
we can use a standard structure learning
algorithm to learn the color
relationship between these variables and
which is realized by the color graph and
the choreograph encodes the uh like
which variable calls it another variable
of the bridge variable does not for
example in this graph the LBD represents
the RBD of the class and side represents
the cloud side and the vertex partition
represents the number of times the class
was involved in propagation and utility
represents the client's utility
and a directing Edge represents the
causal causal relationship between two
factors for example the direct Edge from
LBD to propagation it means that LBD
causes a propagation
the causal graph actually gives us a
good uh realization of the water
relationship between these factors and
how these different components different
factors interact with each other
fiber inside the local graph we only
know the qualitative relationship
between these variables for example we
only know that LBD causes propagation
but we don't don't know that what's the
exact impact of our video on propagation
is that very large or is that very small
and in all in order to get that
quantitative relationship
we have to encode the question of our
interest into into a cloud query and
then use color reasoning to calculate
causal effects and use that effect
answer the original query now let's
start from a simple example like to look
at what kind of query on our approach
can handle
remember in the previous slide which I
showed that we have the Assumption in
modern style solver the Clauses with low
LPD has greater utility
which motivates us ask the following
question which clause with low or high
LBD has greater utility
this question can be encoded into an ate
query an ate in the context of a cloud
resin represents every treatment effect
and this expression ET x y a b
represents the effect on the effect on
the factor y if the factor x changes
from B to a an AR example the 80 power
increase lighter what is it what is the
change of the class utility if the LBD
increases from one to two if this change
is positive it means that as albeit
increases the clouds will utility
increases and therefore a large closet
with high LBD will have a higher utility
which disproves our assumption but if
the if this change is evaluated to be
negative it means as LBD increases the
clouds rotated jobs and we can infer die
to the low LPD class will have a greater
utility which will match our observation
foreign
how do you know within which direction
the causality goes oh I mean how to
learn the direction in the color graph
yeah but but what do your data supports
this uh directionality so how can you
get this out of the kind of data that
you you generate you're not doing
interventions you're not yeah we are not
looking at across from propagating to
see what the effect is but so you're
so how do you how can you conceptually
how can you get that out of the kind of
data you have uh I mean how to get the
data or how to learn a direction from
the data so if you have that data yeah
how can you see in it in which direction
causality yes we can so there are two
calories to get to the direction the one
is you said that we can use intervention
but inside of sales over many variable
Factor we cannot intervene the other way
is to learn from the observational data
that's what we did and there are a bunch
of standard maths that you can learn
from the observational data or for
example uh there will be one called a
hill climbing we start first start from
uh uh empty graph on every step we add
remove or reverse an edge and to see
that if this graph is a data better and
we repeat this process until you
converge to a stable or come
share block
here
and now let's look at uh another type of
question we can answer
uh yeah so in a modern set solver uh for
the data for the clouds deletion
heuristic we use a multi-tire uh
hierarchy that tastes like for the low
LBD class we think that they will be
used for in the long run and restore
them in the first Tire which will be
preserved for a long time fire for the
high lb class which we will Preserve in
the second store in the second tire and
which will be preserved for the short
term because we think that they will
have no use in the near future and which
motivates us following question which
clause with low or high LBD experience a
rapid job in utility overcome
if you look at this question
is asking for the color effect of plan
on class utility but here we have an
extra condition that is either low or
high LBD and in order to answer this
question we have to encode it into a
conditional query that's called Kate
Kate in terms of the color raising is
short for conditional average treatment
effect it means
yeah Kate of x y c a b in the mean side
we have a key part array given a
condition C condition C and in our
example
it means that uh like for low LBD is our
condition and we're including lbds no
more than six
when the RPD is number six
what's the change of the class utility
as a Time increases from zero to ten
thousand if this change is positive it
means that for the low LBD Clauses which
will be less than or equal to 6 is
utility does not job over time
but for the high LBD we have to
condition LBD is greater than six
and we encode it into the kid query
to start to calculate what's the change
of class utility
As Time increases from zero to ten
thousand when RBD is greater than six
and if this change is negative it means
that for the high LBD class it's utility
Indeed jobs overcome
is our final evaluation is independent
negative on for the second one positive
first one it verifies our observation in
um
because delicious every state in modern
style solvers
moreover we can have we can have our
approach support another candle question
yeah I heard this story uh from mate
that in the previous implementation of
the glucose uh the intended to preserve
the large clause or fix the RBD
accurately we think like a small Clause
is more useful but in the previous
implantation glucose for the closet with
steam RBD the previous they preserve the
intent they preserves a large clause
and they found that this kind of
intended implantation surprising how to
perform their intensive implementation
and which motivates us to ask the
following question which type of clause
large or small has greater utility and
motives LBD is fixed
and this question actually has two sub
questions the first is ask what's the
effect of closed sales on Cross utility
that can be encoded into a ate inquiry
similar to the question one it
represents it means that what's the
change of the class your character when
the sides increases from one to two if
this change is negative it means it will
increase the size of class the utility
jobs and then we can improvise the small
class has greater utility
but in order to answer the second
question we need uh there is a special
condition with LBD is fixed in order to
answer this kind of question we come up
with the query called acade
which represents the 80 Wells the
variable Z is fixed
and others are similar to The at in our
example in the main side when LBD is
fixed
what's the change of the uh what's the
change of class utility at the site
increases from one to two if this change
is positive it means that for the
classes with the same with fixed RBD
large Clause has higher at greater
utility and if this evaluation is indeed
positive which will match our
observation in the previous
implementation of glucose
after we formulate the autocracy inquiry
we can use color reasoning to evaluate
this query and get the final uh because
estimate if all of this color estimate
matches the uh the inequality we can
answer the original question
and in this talk we uh escape the
details about the calculation of the
cargo effects because we are more
interested in the answer
how is LBD defined when size is one
the size is one
okay okay
let's go Canada answer the question to
Quarry uh we start from the first
question which clause with low or high
ability has greater utility in the
previous slide we have encoded this
cluster into the AP query which is
finally evaluated to be the negative
number zero point negative 0.26 and the
negative value tells us that has lb
increasing from one to two across
rotated jobs therefore we can draw the
conclusion that low LBD class has
greater utility
for the second question
which class has low or high LBD
experience a rapid job in utility over
time which has been encoded into 2K
query the first query is for the low LBD
class and our data is it was invalidated
to be a positive number 0.638 and the
positive number means that for the low
lb Clause is utility and does not job
over time the second category is for the
high lb clause which evaluation can get
the negative result and the negative
value tells us that uh for the high LD
class its utility actually drops over
time
then we can draw the conclusion of high
LBD class experience a draw a rapid job
in utility overtime which matches our
observation in the cloud deletion
heuristic of modern stat solvers
value for last question which type of
clause large or small has greater
utility what if the LBD is fixed
the first ad party is ability to be a
negative value so we know that the small
Clause has greater utility and the
second acid query is also evaluated to
be an active value so we don't like to
uh as our even for the closet with fixed
LBD as we increase the size from one to
two the class you can play also jobs so
we can draw conclusion small gloves and
still has greater yield the data even
when the LBD is fixed which disproves
the observation in the previous
implementation of glucose but it matches
the implementation in other modern style
solvers
and besides this three kind of question
actually our approach can be used to
answer other interesting questions and
for example we can compare the impact
between two factors and withdrawal
conclusion LBD has greater impact to the
cloud size
and also it can be used to identify the
new factors for the like for example for
the class deletion heuristic besides the
widely used the factor LBD Cloud site
and class activity we found that
propagation has the greatest impact on
Cloud's irritated maybe it can be used
to design a new heuristic for cloud
station heuristic
and moreover we can use it to
investigate the interaction between
different heuristic and we found that
for branch of heuristic Maple leads to
Greater utilities than BC and forward
stock ariste we found that Lupe leads to
the greatest utility against the RBA
based and geometric uh restart heuristic
in a future we plan to start the color
effect on the solving time Ubuntu
investing uh which heuristic and which
factor has a positive effect on the
solving time and which are which carry
steel which factor has a negative impact
on the sovieta which can help better
help us understand how the stat solver
works
and also this framework can be used to
study the hardness or benchmarks we can
study the color effects of the
attributes of Benchmark on the solving
time and this kind of attributes of
Benchmark can include a number of
variables and number Clauses for the
formula and also the three ways of the
Primal graph or trevised graph and it
can be
it can help us to identify like a which
kind of Benchmark is uh which can be a
benchmark is hard for the model size
solver to solve and why we kind of
Benchmark it easy to solve
we hope that our framework and help us
to better understand the how the
standstall works and can motivate the
design of new uh solver heuristics
that's all thank you
[Applause]
okay uh
I'm trying to remember the term but
anyway there's something like
temperature that that Armin
use in order to decide for restart you
you just mentioned Luby and
geometric and things like this but but
it was something like
uh
how many short Clauses have been derived
uh uh in the last
thousand conflicts or something like
this I mean you you when you get a
conflict sometimes you get long calls
sometimes you get short Clauses and and
um so so uh so Armin had some kind of a
way of saying that if if you know if if
you're going good then don't restart but
but if you haven't come up with anything
uh then you're probably in a bad part of
the search space I I you might try to
make a query
something like that
um but but my main the main thing I want
to know usually when I'm running a a set
job is uh
is it close to finishing uh uh you know
I I I I I I can look at things and
saying uh uh
how many propagations do I do per
conflict or something like this uh or I
can say you know how many unit Clauses
have I derived but but it was it's been
sitting there for half an hour uh uh
everyone you know is there any is there
anything I could measure that would tell
me that I'm getting closer to the answer
uh and and so far I haven't I haven't
found that magic thing every every once
in a while you know I'll I'll look at
the result of a two-hour run and and
I've been printing statistics out every
uh every 10 seconds and
and I look at the statistics uh that
that happened
during the last uh minute before it
finally succeeded but I haven't been
able to notice a pattern where I could
note it where I could where I could
predict that I'm getting somewhere
because of course sometimes or a lot of
times it just times out so it's a lot uh
I I I can just sort of encouraging you
to to try to to study something that
that gives gives an indication as to as
to uh progress
oh
yes I think that's very important if you
can have come up with the indicator for
the program
why I think we can use this strategical
method I can't uh like we hope that we
can use this statistical analysis to
find this kind of indicator for the
progress instead of status solver
some sometimes I think it's very uh you
know that easy to Define what's a
progress
and solver
yeah
with the with the look ahead solver I
have no problem
I sort of go lexicographically through
everything uh but with with the CDC
sales algorithm I I don't have any
monotonic uh
indication of how many cases I've looked
at yes I think the first step is to we
have to have a clear and a formal
definition for what's the uh progress is
[Music]
yeah I still have to think about life
yeah yeah so
try to find a combination of of causes
that that's highly correlated with
progression and that goes anyway it
might be possible
by looking at your data to figure some
characteristic I mean I don't know use
uh deep learning or something
thanks
there's uh three quick remarks uh one
thing that I think would be interesting
if if you would compare with their I
mean previous work has been done on
analyzing proof Vlogs from sat solvers
to try to figure out an answer precisely
these types of questions so Lauren
Simone has an old paper post-mortem
analysis we have a
Nordstrom paper in in CPE 2020
um
um and another that the second remark is
that when you do this kind of analysis
it's kind of important that you actually
analyze what the solver did and one of
the things that we saw in RCP 2020 paper
is that the dra trim proof will be very
very different from what the solver
actually did so if you're like trying to
analyze solver performance then you
should not use the dra to improve and
then the third challenge I think for all
approaches so far which would be also
interesting to talk about is that and
the complaint we've been given which I
think is is Justified is that sometimes
when you figure out oh this is better
this is worse
and then you talk to a set practitioner
and they say yeah yeah sure but but
that's just because you're only looking
at this heuristic that I have it's for
set instances and you're only analyzing
onset so when we're saying like this is
bad and this is good somehow we would
need to also think about could we
somehow do generate proofs for set
instances and somehow
um analyze effect also on those
instances because some heuristics when
you talk to the practitioners they might
tell you that this I specifically expect
this to be good
for satisfiable instances and then in
this kind of analysis and also in our
analysis we won't see it because we're
only running on unset instances
are actually the same
all right one game
I I can I can ask two and three maybe
um and maybe I can I can I can say
something about what they're on set so
regarding the derived proof yes I am you
told this to me I didn't believe it for
a year and then I believe you now and I
it's a fraud proof now and um we we have
elaboration and all that stuff so we can
rerun everything here and probably will
take a week or so and it will all over
front so we have fixed this issue we
recognize that you've arrived so you
were second uh like the third thing that
you said about about uh onsat versus SAT
and you know like can we do this over
Assad and we can do this over assault
and actually I did this already uh over
dirat trim I I hacked it so that it
works on South you you have to think a
little bit about it and you can make it
work it's not a big deal actually
um it's a trick that I can explain in
two seconds everybody will get it it's
not a big deal
um and and and then it works over sad so
so it's and and then you can do the
whole thing like the whole thing just
what you so here oversight instances
just as well and we did it so I can
learn over start if I want but that's
over that okay I haven't hacked
throughout yet it's a it's an
interesting code base uh
one day I will I will understand rust
and then I will you know but once I
understand the compiler it changes every
week so
I'll keep at it
and finally uh regarding what what what
what uh Don has said about about
understanding statistics and I actually
agree with you that that we need to use
either machine learning to get there or
uh some kind of experimental statistic I
mean statistical analysis using sort of
data digging you know data explorative
data analysis because we have the data
the problem is that the data is you know
100 gigabytes and no sane person will be
able to understand it so we need to do
something with it and and the best I
personally could come up with was
machine learning and the best young I
mean jiong came up with uh clearly is
better in his causal analysis which I
think is actually better but but
these are both some to some extent
automated methods with some human
interaction
um doing it like like by hand is I I I
don't know if that's possible maybe
somebody who's better at statistics will
give me an answer
[Applause]
foreign